well we'll start uh here as mentioned
i'll be speaking at georgia tech tonight
looking forward to that um journalist
andy noe has the scoop here as he's you
know of course his uh part of what he
does so well is keeping track of antifa
and what they're up to so i learned from
him today he's got the he put the tweet
out
it says the atlanta georgia cell of
antifa is using twitter to try and
organize a direct action to stop matt
walsh's speaking event today at georgia
tech one of the strategies so far by an
in
in antifa furry member is to hoard all
the tickets with fake signups
so this is a this is someone who's in
antifa and they're also a furry
and those things often go hand in hand
by the way not to harp on it or anything
but uh
speaking of people who have never been
told no you know furry that's that's
another example of what happens when
you've got someone their whole life like
no one has ever sat them down and said
no stop this this is insane what the
hell is wrong with you no one's ever
said that and so now these are adults
running around in furry costumes doing
god knows what
um in any case so the atlanta antifa
cell they uh tweeted this is what they
tweeted heads up transphobic
propagandist matt walsh is speaking on
georgia tech campus tomorrow evening in
an event sponsored by the far right
leadership institute at turning point
usa
if tech students are organizing a
counter we'd be happy to boost to boost
it reach out um
and then some other antifa members are
saying that uh
they're gonna that now they're they're
trying to buy up all the tickets
so that there won't be room for actual
you know for people actually want to
listen to the talk i say buy the tickets
tickets are free of course we're not
going to sell tickets to an event like
this um but we do you know you have to
register ahead of time because there's
only there's only so much room in the
room
and so they're tactic and we saw them do
this
down at university of north texas
um where they
got in there first however i don't know
if they registered ahead of time or what
for that particular talk but they got in
there first and they were the only ones
in the room all the people that wanted
to get to the talk couldn't get in and
then they just shut the talk down by
chanting and screaming and spitting and
doing all this kind of stuff so that's
their plan that's what they're going to
try to do tonight well you know with
four kids at home plus a dog who hates
my guts uh there's constantly dirt in
the house and that's why you always got
to stay on top of it and that's why we
use in my house naturally it's clean did
you know that you can get a hospital
grade cleaning product that won't leave
harmful chemicals on all of your
services introducing naturally it's
clean a home cleaning company dedicated
to providing the most effective cleaning
products for your home while reducing
the use of harmful chemicals as well
their secret powerful plant-based
enzymes nature solution to cleaning
naturally it's clean has safer chemistry
formulas to clean every area of your
home from the bathroom to your hardwood
floors to your kitchen all of their
products are manufactured right here in
the usa and they offer two-day free
shipping direct to your door and they're
also again safe which is great too when
you have kids because they're constantly
getting into everything and that's why
you need this product try them for
yourself right now my listeners can get
their hands on the naturally it's clean
daily wire essential kit stocked with
four great products for 15 off simply
visit naturallyitsclean.com
matt and use promo code matt try out
these incredible cleaning products in
your home today for fifteen percent off
by visiting naturallyitsclean.com
matt
now they're gonna run into some problems
trying to do it to me um
for a few reasons one of them being that
you know i think we had so far we have
something like 700 people trying to
register for this event there's only
there's you know like room for less than
half of that in the room so um if they
want to if they want to keep everybody
out they're gonna have they they have to
organize and take up a lot of these
registrations which
i don't think they've been able to do
but we'll see
but the other thing is listen
it doesn't matter what they do and i
want you to understand this okay
if you're in antifa or you're on the
left or whatever you don't like the fact
that i'm coming to speak at georgia tech
you don't like the fact that i'm coming
to speak anywhere else and i've got a
whole college tour coming up this this
spring i'll be going down by the way to
university of north texas where all that
madness happened
i promised you i told you i'm gonna go
and i'm gonna go and i will be there
probably sometime in april we're working
out the details right now and i'll let
you know more about that soon but
um i'm coming to speak at these events
and you don't want me there well i just
want you to know there's literally
nothing you can do to stop it
i will be there and i will say my peace
no matter what you do i will still be
there and i will still say what i came
to say one way or another
you start making a scene and i gotta
wait for you to get carried out of the
room by cops that's fine and then i'll
just resume like there's there's you can
make an ass of yourself you can make a
fool of yourself
that that you can do all that
but you can't stop me from speaking it's
not gonna happen
cannot happen
now the other option that you could try
i'll give the same challenge to antifa
that uh i give to
every you know any any college campus i
go to because there is a q and a session
afterwards so
uh
if
i i'll make the same deal in fact i'll
go even farther this time
if you're on the left
and you show up to this event
and you can
provide a definition of the word woman
that is coherent
and that is also consistent with your
left-wing ideology with gender ideology
like if you could give a gender ideology
consistent definition of woman that's
also coherent to make sense if you can
do that
then i will
retire from public speaking on the spot
i will renounce my conservative
ideals
i will pledge allegiance
to the antifa flag right then and there
if you can do that
that's the deal
let's see
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated